i'm yaroslav i work at shopify and today
you will hear about our apache flank
adoption story so i'm a stop data
engineer and the
big chunk of my career i spend building
different types of platforms but the
last two years primarily focused on
stream processing
and so i had to include this slide about
shopify you know in case you don't know
about us we create the best commerce
tools for anyone anywhere to start and
grow in business and i have some
interesting stats for you like we have
more than 1.7 million merchants in
roughly 175 countries
so i want to start today by telling you
what i'm not going to cover
i'm not going to cover the pipeline so i
know this is very common when you you
know adopt a new tool you have
some kind of use case you go through
this journey maybe you have some kind of
set of data sources event data
databases you
implement different transformations
different data processing maybe write
them to some kind of data store serve
the specific use case um so you won't
hear about that today
the goal of my team
is different so instead of building
those data pipelines those specific use
cases we actually want to make building
and operating flink applications as easy
as building and operating rails
applications
so why rails shopify is a big ruben rail
shop and rails is also well known for
its you know developer experience the
ease of use
so um could be a stretch but we really
wanted to
try to make flank as easy as rails
and why exactly do we need to do that so
we have a lot of different use cases for
real-time data products at shopify so
it's anything like product
analytics reporting data integration
data enrichment sessionization
and all of those different domains all
these different teams you know come to
us come to data platform and asking you
know how can we build those um and it's
literally anyone from like team that's
supporting the core kind of sales
functionality to
inventory marketing billing shipping
mobile teams you name it
and so
um
some can say well you can probably have
like a central team that
you know can implement those pipelines
but i'm also a big believer in data mesh
and my interpretation of data mesh is
really you know really strong ownership
so you actually want the engineers that
work on billing
to implement the transformations that
are going to be used
in the billing product potentially you
don't want to separate those because
you know when you do you have this
different worlds of data folks and you
know engineering or operational folks
and kind of the best products the best
results you get when you actually either
embed data scientists or data engineers
or teach
software engineers back engineer
engineers how to use data tools so we
truly believe in that we're still
going through that journey um but but i
thought this is a this is kind of a very
good explanation on you know why why
even try to make it easy to use
and why apache flink so at shopify we
implemented a lot of different streaming
applications over the years we tried
many technologies like spark structured
streaming apache beam with google data
flow
some internal products but
none of them um you know support really
large
um stateful complex stateful
transformations and none of them feel
just like building another application
like like with rails right because flink
is complex streaming is complex and and
you want to eliminate as much complexity
as possible
so how do you build a data platform
i was thinking about this
for quite a while and i ended up with
this kind of three levels of platforms
that it can build so let me explain
the first one is not really a platform
but i'm going to mention it anyway so
you can use an open source tool like
apache spark or apache flink
um you can add some libraries tools
frameworks documentation and customer
support and whatnot
and you can leverage all of that to
build standalone applications tunnel
applications that those the main teams
will implement and this is what i call
an ecosystem approach
so this is
this is the first level
um we can go into the second level which
is you starting
to build a managed platform uh right so
a single shared managed managed runtime
that can power main use case so shared
is a keyword here and single is secured
here right so if we're looking into
those analogies with open source
maybe tools like emr from amazon or
google data proc they kind of
fit this this paradigm where they
abstract a lot of complexities
you can perceive them as managed
platform and they can be used like one
you know instance can be used to support
many different use cases so
it is sure
and the third level is what i call
serverless
you can notice quotes
and what i really mean here uh when you
take that managed uh platform and you
try to really abstract and automate and
simplify a lot of operational um work
eliminate a lot of toil
you can try to get as you know as close
as possible to the serverless paradigm
so for example auto scaling you know is
something that is somewhat trivial
nowadays with all the cloud tools and
all the you know kubernetes
systems and stuff like that but
you know try try autoscale flink you
know that's not as easy
and again some of the examples in kind
of vendor and open source
um here would be something like google
bigquery right or redshift serverless
and those truly can abstract a lot of
those details so bigquery you open the
ui
you write a single sql statement you hit
a button it runs you don't specify how
many workers you need you don't specify
how many cpu memory disk size all of
that is abstracted so this is kind of
the serverless level
so i want to play a little game
assuming you want to build a platform
raise your hand
if you think you want to build a managed
platform number two
anyone see one hand
okay who want to build a server-less
platform
see more hands i want to build an
ecosystem
not a lot okay i i expected everyone
yeah i see i see you
i expect that a lot of people will say
serverless right uh the right answer of
course uh it depends it depends it's
always the answer
uh it depends because you know
there are multiple dimensions here
multiple angles to look at and
serverless is definitely you know kind
of the coolest one
but
if you try to convince your boss that
you need to spend you know 18 months uh
designing and building and you know
polishing this uh managed serverless
platform well good luck uh it is
justifiable you can definitely build it
but it can be hard even from like
project management perspective and you
know kind of uh stakeholder alignment
and the ecosystem one you know probably
something you can do in a few weeks you
take an open source project you add some
some synthetic sugar you add some
tooling um and you kind of you get going
fairly quickly
the other the other aspect here is the
ease of use right so i i mentioned
bigquery where is the start you write a
sql statement you hit hit a button
but that also means that people will
create a lot of jobs right because it's
so easy right so i can i can use dbt
something else
sql everybody understands so i will end
up with a lot of jobs and
you know i constantly see this problem
with
people maybe writing a lot of jobs and
occasionally you know rework happens or
people leave jobs get abandoned jobs
break
there is not always that great data
reliability set of
practices that we saw earlier today in
every company so that that's a big
problem that's really a problem around
ownership and the fact that you can
easily implement things kind of make it
a bit worse
and so with the ecosystem approach for
example you can enforce it by actually
uh asking people you know you gonna own
that pipeline that job that you
implemented so we're gonna provide you
tools we're gonna provide infrastructure
we're gonna provide you maybe some
frameworks documentation whatever you
need but in the end you are on call you
are going to be responding to 2am pages
and
you know that can be scary and sometimes
it needs some convincing but
in the end that's really viable and you
suddenly don't have a lot of jobs that
abandoned or break all the time just
because people get paged and people
generally aware of what those jobs do
and who is the owner it's very clear
so
at shopify we decided okay let's go with
the ecosystem approach because that's
very easy to implement and let's see if
slowly we can evolve it to that
serverless vision because this is where
everyone want to be you probably want to
try to kind of skip that number two
platform one um as soon as possible just
because you're not getting a lot of
benefits you know one and three is where
you want to be
and the way we approached it um we ended
up you know the first milestone ended up
just being really foundational right so
we came up with the very high level
library that has a lot of reusable
components for example almost everyone
needed to
read data from kafka or write data to
kafka
since we are running on google cloud we
need to interact with uh cloud storage
uh also use bigtable a lot for user
facing
products
and obviously it makes sense to
just create all those connectors battle
test them
and
package them in this library that
everyone can use so that's kind of a
no-brainer situation
observability you probably don't want
people to you know keep reinventing the
way to monitor the same pipeline all the
time so we ended up
implementing a custom metrics reporter
making sure logs can be properly powered
structured and all of that
we also created a repo with a bunch of
examples right so you want to consume
data from kafka do some processing write
it to big table here's an example for
you so it's like a
an application that you can run you can
run locally if you want to and it's very
easy to start using it as a foundation
maybe for something for you
and we also ended up creating a project
generator
i think it was mentioned yesterday
during one of the talks
uh i believe
emily from mailchimp
said that the answer to their problem
for uh you know how to share gpus was
well let's just create a lot of uh you
know let's create a template and ensure
people use templates to to generate
projects and that template abstracts a
lot of complexity and it works and
yeah i wanna i wanna vote again um
project generator is something that's
super low effort uh it needs some
maintaining but if you do maintain it it
can actually solve all the problems so
as a user when you start working on a
new project you
use a tool internal shopify tool called
dev which i'm going to demo in a few
slides and you can get a working project
in 30 seconds which compiles which has
all the classes you need all the
dependencies all the ci and cd tooling
observability all of that local
development
and
it truly allows you to get going like in
in less than a day because you can run
it on your laptop and you know it's very
fast
and obviously because we are supporting
many many many customers and we don't
have a centralized platform yet
we invested a lot in documentation
customer support um and you know any
kind of support we can
now we're on the second milestone where
we're just launching those applications
learning and iterating and
we'll see how that goes
um if you put together all those things
that i mentioned and might be hard to
read i'm just realizing but let me
explain
kind of how these things work together
so we actually started by developing a
lot of those examples like trying to
understand what are the best practices
what do we feel people should be doing
and this is the green box at the bottom
on the right
so we ended up writing a lot of those
examples kind of realized they look good
enough we want to standardize some of
those things
so we created a template based on those
examples
the template is integrated with this
tool called def and when you type def in
it
you get a little prompt that asks a few
questions and in the end you end up with
this orange box
which is the project that's generated so
that thing is you know it's compilable
again it has all those batteries
included and you don't need to do much
you just run it
and finally in order to not re-implement
the same set of connectors or the same
set of you know functionality that's
shared um we have that library and you
see trickle here mentioned all the time
so just to explain trickle is the
internal name of that flink ecosystem in
shopify doesn't mean anything
outside of shopify i guess
yeah so that's kind of the overall
structure of things very scrappy you can
do it in a few weeks and
as long as you maintain all of those
components um kind of things things seem
to seem to work like this model seems to
be working
and now you can ask me so as a
as a user of this ecosystem as an
internal customer what i need to write
actually right and where it leaves so
that library that i mentioned you can
imagine it's like a top level of this
sandwich fling sandwich
that we have we also provide
infrastructure to all the customers so
we think
probably not it's probably not
reasonable to ask people to manage their
own kubernetes right so
fine you won so we're going to manage
infrastructure for you we provide you
with kubernetes clusters deployment
tools observability tools like all of
that
and in the end as a customer you focus
on the business logic and you implement
that flink pipeline
and we're not trying to hide any of the
flank apis like i think it's a mistake
i think fling has apis that are fairly
straightforward and also powerful so
there is no reason for us to like put a
dsl on top of that but we are only
trying to
uh
provide very useful components that can
be shared so in the end we have
infrastructure we have
application
business logic in the middle and we have
some higher level components at the top
that's that library
and now i hope this can work just a
quick demo of that dev tool
literally just typing dev init
in the terminal
then i'm going to select
a new trickle project
then there's a bunch of sbt magic going
on
and
i'll be asked
the name
of the project i want to create
and the package name kind of the main
package
um that's it
we have the project ready and
you will see just a bunch of files here
like fully fully working sbt project
with docker file and all the other ci
stuff so just a quick demonstration
and so what's what's inside that project
um
we thought about this a lot like how do
we
try to avoid enforcing a lot of uh
specific rules but show the best
practices right and how do we explain
how to think about streaming
and this is this is a typical flink
application shopify like the way it's
structured and i'm just going to go
through that and show you like a few
different sections
so first
there is that trickle environment and i
i promise that's the the only
abstraction on top of flink we're not
hiding anything else
but that just generates that streaming
environment
and it does a lot of configuration for
things like checkpointing and some of
the other sterilization
configuration
then we ask the users to define their
sources right because it all starts with
understanding the source what am i
consuming
in this case we have something called
monorail which is internal shopify's
um kafka message format like event based
and we also have a cdc one so change
data capture uh format so we define
those two sources some of them can be in
separate classes maybe because they're
fairly complex have a lot of business
logic some of them can be defined inline
like the cdc one right so you define
your sources
using you you then define your syncs
like where is this data going to uh in
this case we have this kind of enum sync
type which you can change with an
environment variable and you could
decide between simply just printing data
for
local development or debugging or
writing it to bigtable
in this case that's like a production
staging environment
so you define your
sinks
and then you define your transformations
and
maybe this is coming from me reading
kent back very early but
really trying to be very clean at the
high level and
try to express
those kind of fairly complex
transformations with a few lines of code
and then when you go inside you can kind
of understand the details of the
implementation but
based on what you see now you can
understand we do some kind of post
processing on those two sources
we then join them and we aggregate the
results of the join and then we write
them to the sync like that's i guess
fairly straightforward to understand but
if you want to understand the specifics
of those joints and aggregations you
kind of go inside those methods and
you can deep dive into that so that's
overall
how we
how we structure applications and how we
try to educate different users who may
be coming to streaming like that's
that's a viable
approach
yeah that's just the same
result um just a quick snippet from
documentation because i mentioned that
cdc kafka source and i also mentioned
you know we trying to be serious about
docs so we have an internal um you know
data handbook um documentation website
and this is just like a quick snippet
from that where we have a bunch of links
kind of and explaining how to use that
source i guess that's important
for that ecosystem solution to be
self-serve right so you don't want to be
answering how to use that source every
time you just get a snippet done
so now i want to share some of the
lessons we learned going through this
journey
um the first one is we had to fork
apache flink internally and it sounds
very scary but it's not that scary in
practice believe me
so why we had to fork it um some of the
features and early bug fixes we just had
to incorporate them as soon as possible
running flink on gcp was hard a few
major versions ago
just because um you know it wasn't
supporting things like writing to to gcs
for example really well like you can try
um
but it's gonna be a lot of debugging
with hadoop libraries and all of that
and in the end flank has some kind of
limitations so we had to bring that uh
patch as early as possible
things like power key reader
you know before 114 had lots of issues
things like
big decimals of course microseconds
wasn't just dealing with those really
well and some things yeah they just
don't work properly like uh docstatsd
metrics reporter had to implement a
custom one
and some some other minor improvements
and i mentioned you know it's it looks
scary but it shouldn't be um that scary
uh and i wanted to show a couple of
slides about how we maintain that fork
because i find it's very hard you know
to
find these things online like how big
tech companies kind of maintain their
open source
forks and this model works really well
when you don't have a lot of active
development like you're not trying to
stay close to the main branch but maybe
you have like a handful of changes here
and there
less than 10 let's say
that you want to maintain
and the way it works in our case is very
simple
every time a new major version of link
releases they create a git tag
the nice property of git tags is very
immutable
so we create an internal branch in our
in our fork
based on that tag
prefix shopify
and then we can add a bunch of custom
changes to that branch build it
if you want to contribute things
upstream to to the open source flank you
have all those commits available and you
can like you can copy paste them in
practice there's actually a third kind
of repo in the middle which is a public
fork where we copy things over first
then create a pr against
the upstream
but what happens like the beauty of this
model is what happens when there's a
major release new major release so let's
say
one 115 happened there's new git tag you
create a new branch
and
it's as easy as cherry picking some of
those commits from the previous branch
to the new one right
so
that works really well we've done
one of those major upgrades and yeah
this
seems to be working well like this this
model but as i said in our case we have
kind of 10 or less custom changes
and then of course we have to build it
we have some ci jobs to build the
artifacts to build
the distribution of flink and then build
the base docker image that we kind of
share and advertise at shopify that you
know you should be using this liquor
image instead of the public one
data reconciliation so this is a bit
orthogonal but i thought i'm going to
mention it just because there's a lot of
talk about like data validation data
reliability in this conference
i think all those
all of those are important
data reconciliation here is more about
data integrity reconciliation not really
data validation
because a lot of those
projects projects that we see they are
migrations right so people migrating
from batch jobs to streaming or people
migrating from older streaming tools to
flink and typically you have the new
data set that you know flink generated
and an old data set maybe in in the
object store maybe in kafka somewhere
and so you want to have a tool that can
simply look at those two data sets and
reconcile them right to see
you know simple things like counts do
they even match do they have any data
laws
and we have this kind of integrity
check service that's running in
background
but it can be as simple as just writing
a couple of notebooks and literally
comparing results
and this helps this truly helps uncover
some of the really tricky bugs because
even if counts match you know maybe
you're performing some aggregation and
data is skewed or something
yeah so you need some kind of better
better integration
integrity
test
tools
in order to scale this adoption we
actually needed to involve more than a
single team right so i am part of that
streaming capabilities team
that maintains all the score components
like the library
you know tooling infrastructure
deployment all of that
and
we needed to have a second team so we
actually have this internal customer
success team and data platform at
shopify and they act serve as internal
consultants so they help us with uh you
know triaging some bugs and maybe
escalating them only if needed helping
people with onboarding
uh really acting as like consultants
almost like a solution architects
internally and participating in
technical designs with customers
and
white glowing first key customers
because you need to get that initial
adoption like you need to get those
initial first few customers that you can
then show to everyone that hey i
actually have adoption right
so that's important and
i think it would be very hard for us to
you know just be a single platform team
trying to uh trying to provide all those
tools and
uh you know customer adoption is
something that's critical again just
because we are not implementing a
central managed runtime which you know
takes care of some of those concerns but
we are trying really to shift that focus
to the application developers
and yeah they ask a lot of questions and
you should be ready with your
documentation with your self-serve tools
and
potentially a team of you know
consultants i guess
of course you know it works for bigger
companies but even in small companies
you can have just a handful of people
occasionally wearing that solution
architect hat and helping you know if
you're following kind of
the same approach
build a community so that's uh was very
important too we realized
and you know we have of course things
like internal q a website where people
just go and ask questions we have a
bunch of slack channels but the
interesting one is this uh you know
meetups that we created so regular um
meetups for flank users all those
internal teams in the company they you
know meet up every month they share
different
use cases they build different pipelines
learn from each other and you know as a
platform team we don't need to do much
in this case we just kind of we need to
avoid you know interfering people people
uh you know smart they
they know what to share and kind of
learn from each other so
that's been very helpful
so as a result
in less than six months we had three
very largest cases in production and uh
10 plus prototypes running
and i presented about one of those
prototypes at flink forward last year
and there is also an article in our blog
about how we
implemented black friday cyber monday
live map
with flink
and part of that map was actually
in new york on times square on a
billboard
during black friday uh and that
billboard was powered with flank which
is kind of nuts uh but uh yeah i think
that's a cool use case so check check
out that that blog post if you're
interested
uh in terms of next steps you can ask
you know we've done this first milestone
we somewhat successful we got some
adoption um of course our initial sorry
our final goal would be that serverless
runtime for sure um i guess we
understand the importance and uh the
plan for us is to try to reuse all those
building blocks
that we have now or you know still
building so for example we really want
to focus on production maturity right we
provide infrastructure we provide
deployment tooling we want to make it
much much better
we
we want to have auto scaling you know
fling now has auto scaling for the last
few major versions
i guess it's still
still kind of annotated as mvp
but i think it's ready for prime time
and things like zero downtime
deployments like those are really hard
to implement with streaming because it
all depends on the data syncs right
where the data is coming
to and you know it's very different
in different applications so it's hard
to have that kind of central
central way of zero down time but
i think we found something something
interesting
and also focusing on new features right
so we recently updated to the new latest
version of flink 114 115 i think is
coming or already released so we'll need
to upgrade again
but we've got this really nice
abstraction called hybrid source
and if you if you're still skeptical
about cap architecture for example uh
google flink hybrid source and i hope
that's going to be a bit more convincing
because it allows you to combine your
historical data on like s3 for example
with a live topic in kafka very
seamlessly from from the flink
perspective so you just define two
sources and you tell how to initialize
the kafka topic based on what offsets or
what time stamps and it just works
feels like magic
python support like all of that
work we've done using skull api and
i thought we're going to be seeing some
resistance but surprisingly you know
people who haven't touched jvm before
you know they were kind of very excited
about this and you know scholar that you
write in like spark or flink is very
different from scholarly that you would
write in like a back-end service with
you know cats or some other
very functional libraries so um
scala is not that scary it's not that
hard if you are just building those data
applications and literally just trying
to use uh flink apis right not not
trying to invent anything anything too
hard
um and we also work in a bunch of
integration so iceberg yes that's the
choice that shopify made for data
formats and
and iceberg they have very nice
integration but also a lot more
integrations coming for us integrations
with internal
set of tools and more
and to summarize just like a few key
learnings i wanted to take away
i presented you different approaches
kind of how to think about this platform
building exercise and the answer is
always it depends so choose carefully
the typical strategy that works really
well for for me for example is always
building the foundation first and
engaging a bunch of early customers and
just iterating from there not trying to
foresee what people will need in like 12
months because that usually doesn't work
sometimes you have to have more control
over that key technology that you
adopting so for example forking flink
was a necessary evil you can say
but in the end it
worked out pretty well
we created a community and we basically
had to spend a lot of time with those
first key customers and really show them
the value of the second system but once
we get them like it became very easy to
convince everyone after that
and you know keep it rating focus on the
biggest gaps this is what we're trying
to do right now i guess by really
understanding the strength of the
offering and
working on the gaps
that's it i'm happy to answer your
questions you can hit me up on twitter
and of course we are hiring
thank you
[Applause]